el último rebrote de coronavirus ha
obligado a las autoridades de hong kong
a retrasar la elección de su jefe
ejecutivo estaba previsto que este
domingo se abriera el periodo de
nominaciones entre los 1500 miembros del
comité electoral y que la votación se
celebrará a finales de marzo pero la
pandemia desaconseja ahora cualquier
tipo de reunión y la votación se
celebrará el 8 de mayo un mes y medio
después de la fecha prevista el anuncio
de carril am la actual jefe ejecutiva
llega solo dos días después de que el
presidente chino xi jinping le aclarase
de que el control de la pandemia era su
única prioridad la quinta ola ha
sorprendido a hong kong después de haber
superado sin rasguños las anteriores
nunca había sumado más de 200 casos
diarios y ahora cuenta ya con 4000 y las
y los pronósticos más pesimistas hablan
de 30 mil el mes que viene
el brote ha saturado a los hospitales
que estos días aparcan a los enfermos en
camillas a las puertas del centro carril
am ha descartado que vaya a ordenar un
encierro estricto como los que se
ordenan en el inte hong kong es que
todos tendrán que someterse a una prueba
pcr